okay I'm hello and welcome how come
interesting hello and welcome to this
video meet our boys so something like
that get a king no I felt okay okay very
early c6 it should be rather comfortable
this position
the ad looks comfortable slav Greenfeld
mix the problem with those Slav setups
if you mix it with the groom filed with
the fianchetto the problem is a little
bit that you lack pressure in the center
and this is often it's often a bit
passive you can probably just go back to
ca but might might net be okay well let
me sometimes what I wanted to say I
should have taken on d5 first here in
this position I can place your life not
all but it's not ideal okay let's do it
anyway
I think I'll go g-form not not anymore
and maybe still I'm not sure that is
that it is helping okay let's step out
of the possible tempe it's very slowish
it's almost ready for 45 here
maybe g-form g4 night takes and take one
at five this is actually good ok so now
i can take 992 man this should be nice
after f5 white white should be better
long-term let's see I think I take it
should give a good structure and just
talk g1 sugar for this kind of thing One
Nights you for me ok this is a good move
in most cases i guess it will fit rather
well ok this one ok let's go game 45
[ __ ] the easy for him to play this Kenny
bump you maybe can go a five
we will see
should still be a little bit better I
can go 96a by the way after you five
that is an idea not sure if it is good
really here but ok let's rather passive
looking ok let's just double him
when I def 6s Bishop to g5
maybe rook rook first ok this is I know
is in this in this diagonal maybe it
doesn't really hurt him but here
threatening rook g6 okay so i can take
now let me start with this you cannot
take edge for you anyway you might have
some e five I have bishop geez Bishop f7
but not sure how much that does can
shaky I it to something it does
something
check okay i can take age six or i can
take you five first
I think I'll take him now this one and
five looks like the more important pawn
its age six and you for they both stay
weak check now that's a big big folk
let's not do that oh it's got night age
40 did I blunder this that that's
unfortunate after having a plate rather
decent game I felt blundering into some
some one mover now that's a shame okay
anyway anyway to continue this time
morning
yeah some blunder that was the way to
possibly lose this but maybe I I get
this back somehow that would be
immensely lucky night maybe I get the
bishop bag or some other material that
would be completely undeserved now you
can donate h4 check
ah how can I lose this kind of gamer
which is completely playing on one goal
the whole time you can sit by one
numbers this is the way to do it maybe
it falls for rook takes f6 but that
looks unlikely how to fall for that what
what movers is supposed to play
check check no it's made okay he's not
not really playing great yeah to be
perfectly honest there could have been
could have been easier check is I'm
going to see absolutely no reason to
resign him
check check check never know chat some
kind of stalemate might happen wait for
its on time yeah anyway hair was really
terrible after after he had such a
rotten position oops yeah I just I just
went into him some kind of stupid
suicidal self walk there yeah chants
just a winning position nothing more
nothing less Bishop age 6 is probably
easiest but ya did it just it just it
just it's not good yeah I cannot go to
e2 and it's a cell frog that's really
stupid after this he's got the wrong
position that he deserves after that
plane likes just falling apart down I've
got an extra porn the H porn two bishops
over just over and here yeah I was
thinking this is the best but I have no
except they didn't see that this is
forked this is the thing you can play
whatever you want sorry whatever you can
achieve strategic app you'll run into
night Fox you just you just you cannot
win a game now here I'm yeah I needed to
go for damage control but this was the
idea of course i was thinking I'm just
winning here but she has a smooth and
it's a fork as simple as that yeah I
could have resigned but
check check well it's like to continue
little Jaffa was totally winning before
you never know what happens yeah that's
a bit frustrating there's this other
games that that costs the points yeah
the stupid mistakes are running into a
night fork when you are completely
winning with the technical plane okay
thanks for watching